a new push today to protect cyclists the
campaign kicked off this morning to
remind both drivers and cyclists
how fast things can become tragic if
you're not careful on the road
our hector mejia breaks down the trend
that gave way to this new program
the number of new bicycles on the
roadways is in the thousands here in
town so this is an effort to educate
this new wave of cyclists
enjoying the roadways and trails here
during the pandemic
safety advocates gathered in front of a
memorial honoring the five cyclists
killed back in december by a suspected
dui driver
along u.s 95 near searchlight when the
pandemic rolled in
cycling became one of the top three
activities to pass the time
with 65 percent of new cyclists now
projected to stick with that passion
the ride safe no before you go campaign
highlights these critical safety points
protect your head with a helmet be
visible with lights and bright colors
use bicycle friendly routes with slower
speeds and less
traffic ride defensively don't assume a
driver can see you
it's also critical for cyclists to
try to make themselves safe as well and
so that's what
prompted the the ride safe campaign
in the last few months we've adopted new
ordinance to clarify
the rules of the road so that both
motorists and cyclists know what they're
supposed to do
on some of those narrower roads we've
also expanded
the miles and miles of bike lanes that
we have here in southern nevada
to welcome new cyclists the southern
nevada bicycle coalition is hosting a
social fundraising event on sunday may
2nd
group rights for all levels starting at
7 a.m at lifetime
green valley the southern nevada bicycle
coalition also redesigned its website
offering additional resources
to this new wave of cyclists reporting
near town center drive in the 215 hector
mejia
8 news now